some are saying clarence thomas
is saving more black lives than black
lives matter
because if you look at statistically in
the u.s population right u.s population
60
are white the u.s population 60 is white
blacks is 12.2 percent let me say that
one more time
five times more is the population of
whites versus blacks okay
meanwhile 37 of all abortions are black
women versus 33 percent of abortions are
white
so even though whites are five times the
amount of blacks
the abortion for blacks is higher than
whites which is six times the amount of
abortions a you know
blacks get then why so some people say
well that's racist
well the racist in that topic can be
seen in two different ways because more
black kids
are being aborted than white kids are
being aborted so who is the racist does
that decrease the chances of more blacks
having a voice in the community make a
difference if we're getting five times
more to kids to be aborted and you know
back in the days this was a conspiracy
on the fact that they were doing this
because with the whole crowd you know
all the stories that was going on this
is a way to eliminate from
hey let's go out there and do this
because this can help us uh with the
amount of voice that they could have
there is that topic that's coming up as
well when you're looking at the stats in
regards to what's going on with uh
clarence thomas but
if you if you break it down in the state
you're the governor
here's how the governor says look
in our state
we don't want to do
abortions you don't like it guess what
if an if a governor really supports this
this is how the governor's approach
should be
we don't
but
there are 17 states you can go to where
you can get it
okay very simple go to the 17 states
okay
you know if somebody
protests and riots against somebody that
doesn't allow same-sex marriage guess
what that state governor can say
we don't
but there's these 17 states that you can
go to that does they support you go to
that state
so
now pat that's racist well let me tell
you what i did i'm in california and i'm
against the 13 and a half percent state
taxes then the gas taxes and this taxes
and regulation all this other stuff and
guess what governor newsom said
he said to me indirectly
well if you don't like it
there's these seven states that you
don't pay taxes and guess what i said i
said you know what i appreciate the
offer governor newsom i moved to texas i
lived in texas for five years and 18
months ago
we moved to florida right to be in a
state like this because i like the way
the governor handled it so my position
here to those that are losing their
minds is the following
the hypocrisy is when people are rioting
and protesting in states where abortion
hasn't changed california you're fine
you're fine protesting in your it's very
weird that you're protesting you're not
affected by this this is affected
some other states that are doing it i
say oh i agree go and protest that's one
of the freedoms that we have in america
but just like a business owner can
choose to leave to another state because
they have low regulation and lower taxes
to allow them to hire more people you
also have the choice to move to a
different state that gives you those
freedoms to do whatever you want to do
with your body
is that uh uh discriminatory i don't
know i think you have a choice so if
you're in a state that doesn't allow you
and that really infuriates you you have
two choices try to make the change in
that state which is kind of what you
were talking about right or number two
go move to a state that allows you to do
that you have a choice it's america
you're not
and you now have major employers saying
that they will pay for the travel now
now are they really saying well paying
for maternity leave is a lot more
expensive than paying for an abortion
but uh
first of all i would say two things
pulling any question in the eye of the
storm is very difficult you're gonna get
you're gonna get a skewed result do you
agree with the decision that that
implies people know what the decision
means
many of my friends said abortion is now
illegal everywhere well that's not what
this decision says so
what this looks like in three months
could be very different than what it
looks like today depends on it depends
on
public understanding of the issue which
i'm not sure is there today i like what
you said um polling in the eye of the
storm was is what how did you describe
it yeah
yes exactly it's what
well whenever you try to take a survey
in the middle of a crisis exactly
emotions play a a huge role right until
things settle down and public opinions
are more set
uh when you're in the middle of the
controversy is not the time to measure
the impact of well that's the time that
people are gonna wanna you're gonna send
them into the country
well yeah but even though recognizing it
may be temporary mm-hmm well let me say
one thing
the
as always just like in the economy just
everything with kovid
who's going to get hurt the most the
poor
like the poor don't have the luxury of
just moving to another state or having
their amazing fortune 500 corporation
pay for their abortion who says who says
who says i was poor we moved to america
immigrants come to america they're rich
i'm sorry do immigrants who come to
america are rich immigrants poor
immigrants i'm talking about state to
state though no but that's even easier
it's easier to go to another state than
to come to a country
people are going to go move to another
state they want to get on a mentor are
you kidding me that's a vision
they don't have to move they just have
to go there for the procedure yeah you
you so if you're in the if you're in the
in the belly of texas and you gotta how
what's the closest state to texas that
you can go get an abortion california
okay so how long is that going to take i
mean i'm just saying it's not it's not
as easy
as
all right no move no but i tell you i
tell you when we when i was in
california and i was broke
guess where i went to a dentist
where where mexico mexico jesus
yes okay you you know what the prices of
mexico compared to what it is in
california i would drive five and a half
hours to go to tj to see my dentist that
didn't speak english
i went there and he got it done and it
was good enough your beautiful teeth
easier so the point i'm trying to make
you i was poor
i was 49k in debt and i had barely 500
bucks in a bank i had no money but i'm
like listen my teeth are killing me i
can't even stay so
i get what you're saying on the fact
that you have the choice to go to
another state look just like the rest of
us move if you don't
like where you're living at and there
40 million immigrants
are in america
where do they leave
if the situation was so great they would
have never left
they left because they were not happy
with something if you're not happy
living in a state that's red or purple
and is disagreeing with your views i
highly recommend you move to oregon move
to california move to new york move to
chicago it's more of people that agree
with you look the story of ayn rand with
atlas shrugged what is the story you
know the story is there's a city that
you go to where you're around
like-minded people if you want to be
around like-minded people and you afford
this
or any of this stuff there's plenty of
states for you so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]